[Music]
on this saturday night closing in on
kiev
russian forces inch closer to the
ukrainian capital and are accused of
bombing a mosque and killing children in
the south the violence sparking fresh
calls for peace talks
we are ready to negotiate but we are not
going to accept any ultimatums and
surrender
plus how the conflict is fueling soaring
costs in canada
pig problems why this invasive species
is sparking concerns from
environmentalists and canadian pork
producers
and turning red how the canadian behind
pixar's new hit movie is inspiring a new
generation
global national
reporting tonight
jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us it was another deadly day in ukraine
russian forces bombarding villages
around the capital and claiming new
territory in the south ukraine's
president says some 1300 ukrainian
troops have died since the fighting
began but as those casualties mount the
ukrainian government insists it will not
surrender abigail beeman begins our
coverage tonight
bombing intensifies closer and closer to
the ukrainian capital
peaceful civilians we weren't doing a
thing this man says struggling to
understand why his village was destroyed
according to british intelligence
russian ground forces are just 25
kilometers from kiev we are ready to
negotiate but we are not
going to accept any ultimatums and
surrender i'm highly skeptical that the
russians will be able to take keefe
simon miles says munitions coming from
nato allies including canada's anti-tank
weapon systems will make a difference in
the house to house and street fighting
he expects to see
those types of weapons deployed in
houses
overlooking streets
are going to be able to do an
extraordinary amount of damage to a
russian invading force which is going to
be
perennially sort of perpetually
needing to watch out for shadows and
windows meanwhile in the south along the
border ukraine says russia has captured
mariopol's eastern edges
i don't know where to run who will bring
back our children this mother asks
clutching one child another killed by
shelling there are reports a mosque
sheltering more than 80 people including
children was hit too according to the
city council nearly 1600 civilians in
the encircled city have been killed
buses line up to try and bring aid a
complicated mission while the u.n is
worried about reports of looting and
violence out of desperation for supplies
ukraine's first deputy prime minister
visits a train station in poland trying
to plan a route to get more water food
and medicine into her country fast we
don't have weeks or months
and that's why
we need this assistant right now we need
your help
today of course more than two million
ukrainians have already left their
country i can't speak without
tears i'm sorry but i'm really sorry for
my country and nobody could expect this
really this is awfully awful things
while others don't want to leave
volunteers help evacuate or pin a city
right next to keeve they don't
see the future for them
that nobody is waiting for them anywhere
so they want to stay there but we are
trying to
tell them that you guys have to leave
everything and run
leave everything and run afraid of what
may come next if they don't
abigail beam global news ottawa
meanwhile the leaders of france and
germany spoke today with the russian
president hoping to secure a ceasefire
but a french government official said
that vladimir putin did not show a
willingness to end the war it comes as
u.s president joe biden ramps up trade
and economic sanctions against russia
but as jennifer johnson reports those
sanctions are also having an impact far
beyond russia's borders
u.s president joe biden squeezing
russia's economy even tighter now
banning imports of big-ticket russian
products like caviar and diamonds and
stopping exports of u.s luxury goods
high-end cars and watches desired by
president vladimir putin's billionaire
backers they support putin they steal
from the russian people deutsche bank
has now joined hundreds of companies
across the globe pulling its business
out of russia
but putin continues to brush off the
impact of sanctions as he ramps up
deadly attacks in ukraine i think the
the main idea is to kill ukrainians as
much as they can the biden
administration is under growing pressure
from 40 republican senators to change
course and get poland's mig fighter jets
into ukraine even if that means through
a u.s military base we've gone from
incompetent by the biden administration
to this move is dishonorable president
biden still has more economic weapons he
could launch at russia including
directly sanctioning its stock market
and the country's largest state-owned
banks
but actions have ripple effects
including skyrocketing gas prices in the
u.s after america stopped buying russian
oil can you give me a loan it was over
50
airline ticket prices are rapidly rising
too as the cost of jet fuel
surges the u.s is facing another crisis
from the war dozens of ukrainian
refugees flying to mexico to try and get
into america i don't have any other
place to go i have family and friends in
usa and they're ready to support me but
the u.s border is still officially
closed to asylum seekers due to covet 19
restrictions after multiple attempts a
few ukrainians are getting through to
have their cases heard right now we have
a trickle that's turning into a stream
that's going to turn into a flood the
u.n says more than 2.5 million
ukrainians have fled their country since
the war began next week the president
will sign a spending bill giving ukraine
nearly 14 billion dollars in military
and humanitarian aid but many lawmakers
and americans watching ukraine crumble
under russia's attacks say it's not
enough
jennifer johnson global news washington
and as jennifer mentioned the war in
ukraine is fueling record gas prices
around the world including here in
canada and there are now growing calls
for governments to help provide some
relief at the pumps that topic is
topping the agenda on this week's
edition of the west block with our chief
political correspondent david aiken
david
well jeff you know lots of people right
across the country took note of the
action taken by alberta premier jason
kenney this week when he announced that
in response to the rise in energy prices
his government is going to cut the
amount of tax on a liter of gas and
starting april 1st will provide a rebate
of 150 bucks on electricity bills and
that is essentially returning some of
the windfall profits that his government
is taking in with oil selling north of a
hundred dollars a barrel now the federal
government will also be seeing higher
revenues because of soaring oil prices
and so i asked federal natural resources
minister jonathan wilkinson if his
government might consider a similar
rebate program to help ease the pain of
pump prices
i recognize that this is a big challenge
for many canadians
and and we need to figure out what the
best way to actually address that is um
it certainly can be in terms of pushing
forward with with encouraging people to
uh to utilize uh zero emission vehicles
and those kinds of things which are not
nearly as sensitive to the price
it certainly can involve a look at the
windfall profits that the oil and gas
sector is actually making during this
period of time we also have former bank
of canada governor stephen polazz on the
program and he cautions that markets
themselves tend to have a way of
bringing oil prices back down to earth
high oil prices usually are their own
cure right because they they destroy
demand and that causes people to drive
less et cetera and also would normally
prompt a supply response and so usually
high oil prices don't last that long
one thing we have heard from federal
politicians there will be no pause on
the schedule increase to the federal
carbon tax that's going up april 1st the
trudeau government though could look at
other policies that might make it into
this year's federal budget and it is a
budget that we expect to be tabled in
april jeff
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
and there are fears moldova which
borders ukraine to the west could also
be pulled into the war moldova is home
to a sizeable minority sympathetic to
moscow it also has a breakaway republic
that remains under the control of
pro-russian rebels and that's where more
than a thousand russian troops are
stationed right now mercedes stephenson
reports
[Music]
moldova is a small country under
enormous geopolitical pressure
facing an influx of hundreds of
thousands of refugees from ukraine and
the fear it could be next on russia's
hit list
we are nowadays ukraine and ourselves
are on the border
between
russia and the west and we need the
support to to be able to maintain this
stability it's in everyone's interest
the country is teetering with economic
challenges and political divides that
are being exacerbated by the building
humanitarian crisis and the situation
could rapidly become critical without
more help soon
i don't even want to
consider that scenario it's
it's dire
there's fear in moldova that they may be
next after ukraine the country is not a
nato member and unlike ukraine it has a
very small military around 5000 people
some here believe that putin will test
the west by trying moldova next
publicly officials insist that
everything is fine and there's rare
unity and messaging between the
opposition and the government who fear
triggering domestic unrest
russians have strategically destabilized
this country for the better part of
three decades there is also concerns
that any sign of instability here could
give the russians an excuse to invade to
create
an uh horizon detroit
for russians to interfere to save
russia's people in moldova there are
already russian troops on moldovan soil
in the rebel breakaway republic of
transnistria a self-declared country
that is not even recognized by russia
but heavily supported by it this is one
of the main factors of risk to moldovan
national security transnistria even has
its own military and it's the same size
as moldova's
intelligence analysts believe russian
troops could come back through
transnistria to attack odessa in ukraine
or moldova we tried to go to
transnistria to see what's happening
there but we were stopped at the border
so we just tried to cross over into
transnistria that was unsuccessful they
saw our cameras in the back typically
television crews not allowed in and
clearly we fell into that category
essentially what happened is we pulled
up they took our passports went in they
were gone for
a while we're not sure what they were
doing at that point possibly trying to
search figure out who we are but we do
have a drone and we do have cameras in
the back and of course we also have
press id we don't um hide the fact that
journalists with clearly the materials
that we have on us um so they did not
allow us to enter but it was quite
interesting because we were able to see
people in their transit history in
uniforms this is a breakaway republic it
is not internationally recognized but
you can see
they're organized even though we didn't
get very far we did see evidence of the
russian peacekeeping troops stationed
there behind that green fence is a
russian armored personnel carrier
mercedes stephenson global news kishow
in other news saudi arabia has carried
out the largest mass execution in modern
history killing 81 prisoners the
state-run saudi press agency says those
executed today were convicted of various
crimes including murder meanwhile
prominent saudi blogger rafe badawi is
finally free after 10 years in prison
but the saudi regime says he can't leave
the kingdom for a decade badawi was
imprisoned on charges of insulting islam
back in 2012. he was released on friday
with a 10-year travel ban and he's also
barred from using social media during
that time under those conditions badawi
won't be able to travel to be with his
wife and three children who live in
quebec they were granted asylum in
canada following his arrest
ahead nearly two years since one of
canada's worst shooting sprees an
inquiry gets set to hear testimony from
the gunman's former partner
a powerful storm is sweeping across the
eastern u.s and atlantic coast bringing
up to 15 centimeters of snow in some
spots environment canada says areas near
the water could also see up to 60
millimeters of rain by the time the
system passes through
well it was one of canada's worst
shooting sprees nearly two years ago 22
people died in port-au-prince nova
scotia when a gunman went on a rampage
the public inquiry examining that
tragedy will resume at the end of this
month and we'll hear from three rcmp
officers who responded as ross lord
reports commissioners also plan to call
the person who knew the gunman best
as the common law partner of a man who
killed 22 people lisa banfield will be a
key witness at the public inquiry into
the port of pick massacre she's a very
important
part of of what happened that night
and and
an important part for the process as
well the gunman gabriel wartman
disguised himself as an rcmp officer
killing 13 neighbors while setting
houses on fire including his own just to
let you guys know we're now getting
reports that there's possibly multiple
victims fatalities after slipping past
rcmp officers who responded in puerto
pick he murdered nine more people the
next day before police killed him
the massacre started after wartman
assaulted banfield and she escaped into
the woods lawyers for victims families
say it's crucial for banfield to tell
the inquiry everything she saw and heard
so we anticipate that we will hear from
her
and as with other witnesses under a
subpoena
security analysts caution banfield's
testimony is only one piece of an
enormous body of evidence being
collected by the mass casualty
commission we have to measure to what
extent
someone's testimony is likely only going
to replicate information that the
commission already has by other means
banfield has been questioned several
times by rcmp investigators telling them
the killer was controlling physically
abusive and that he told her over the
years when i go out i'm going out with a
bang
but she says she never anticipated he'd
kill anyone let alone embark on a
diabolical rampage other witnesses make
similar observations including the
killer's uncle a retired rcmp officer
who thought when he gave him these
police boots and other clothing they'd
be used for home decor not as part of a
systematic slaughter that's left a trail
of trauma across nova scotia
ross lord global news halifax
coming up feral swine bomb the invasive
species sparking concerns over their
potential to spread disease
[Music]
you're watching global national
welcome back it's being called a ticking
swine bomb millions of wild pigs are
reproducing spreading and eating their
way across north america for the new
reality this week candice daniel
explores the growing environmental and
financial cost on both sides of the
border candace they have the ability to
cause considerable damage in a short
amount of time
wild pigs are an invasive species and
pose a serious threat so much so that
the u.s department of agriculture has
called the problem a feral swine bomb
they have the potential to cause
catastrophic economic and ecological
harm in the u.s alone causing more than
two and a half billion dollars in
damages every year
rachel sharp manages her family seed
farm in south carolina they have lost
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
feral pigs it is so disheartening to
spend so much time and so much money
putting a crop in the ground and then
seeing it come up and look okay
and go back the next day and it's
completely mowed down in addition to
crop and property damage wild hogs also
carry diseases and harmful bacteria so
they can serve as a reservoir for
african swine fever so the big concern
is these wild pigs getting infected
moving closer to
the areas of domestic production and
then transmitting it which would require
the complete elimination of those
domestic herds african swine fever or
asf is a viral disease with a high
mortality rate for swine the concern in
canada is if it gets into the wild or
domestic pig population here the borders
could close
for canadian pork producers like jurgen
precious this would not only devastate
his farm but hurt the entire industry
too if you have wild
pigs like this come onto your yard and
then whatever disease they may be
carrying transmits to our animals then
it puts the whole industry at risk the
canadian government says the pork
industry generates upwards of 24 billion
dollars to the economy every year
experts are also researching ways to
effectively control the feral swine
population and are urging action to be
taken now
candace daniel in toronto thanks candace
and you can watch candace's full story
on the impacts of invasive wild pigs
that's tonight on the new reality right
here on global
coming up how an oscar-winning canadian
filmmaker is inspiring the next
generation of animators
[Music]
welcome back award-winning toronto
filmmaker domi she is blazing a trail in
the world of animation her latest film
called turning red is generating plenty
of buzz with fans praising the latest
pixar blockbuster after its debut
yesterday she calls the project a love
letter to the city she grew up in and
now she's returning to her roots to
inspire the next generation kayla mclean
has her story
it's a coming-of-age film about a
chinese-canadian girl who turns into a
panda a love letter to the 4-1-6 full of
toronto touchstones the cn tower ttc
streetcars and toronto's chinatown it
was my first time
like living outside of of canada now
domi she the toronto creator of the
pixar film turning red has come back
home to give advice to her younger self
400 animation students from sheridan
college packing this auditorium in
oakville to hear one of their own speak
it's awe-inspiring to see somebody that
graduated in 2011 10 years out of school
directing a film that i think is going
to be a huge hit michelle hannon who
taught she animation at sheridan says
she's watched her former student soar
winning an oscar for her short film bow
and now becoming the first asian woman
to direct a pixar feature film i think
any student right now that sees
similarities in themselves with her will
feel like some doors and
gates or whatever she had said or
opening i see her succeed and like now i
feel like i can do that for third year
stop-motion student sima nasim it's the
diversity and she's work that stands out
the toronto she knows but doesn't always
see on the big screen the first time i
ever saw a pixar movie with like people
of color was it was made by domi she and
that really inspired me because i'm
pakistani like canadian i grew up in
toronto too she's turning red not only
puts canada on the animation map but a
spotlight on homegrown talent too
starring canadian darlings like maitre
ramakrishnan we were just at the cn
tower even sandra oh toronto was never
like the eighth spa in media she being
unapologetically canadian in her work is
a point that cassius appreciates i'm so
thankful that now with uh turning red
kids can see the cn tower they can see
the sky dome i know that if i was a kid
right now and i was watching this i'd be
so proud to be from toronto canada kayla
mclean global news
that is global national for this
saturday i'm jeff semple tonight your
canada is near wycliffe bc and don't
forget that it's time to spring forward
for daylight time that's everywhere
except in saskatchewan so remember to
set your clocks ahead one hour before
you go to bed and expect to feel extra
tired tomorrow thanks for watching hope
to see you back here tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]